[Musique]
bonjour je suis ravi de vous retrouver
ici depuis bruxelles depuis le coeur du
parlement européen
dans ce nouveau numéro d' europe hebdo
nous allons ouvrir ensemble les portes
de l'europe
et voici le programme de cette émission
une émission spéciale puisque david ça
se lit le président du parlement
européen est notre invité nous
reviendrons bien sûr avec lui sur cette
crise sanitaire et économique sans
précédent que le monde et l'europe
traversent avec cette réponse européenne
ce plan de relance qui se dessine porté
par le couple franco allemand
mais nous reviendrons sur bien d'autres
sujets le bric site l'état de droit mais
aussi quel avenir pour l'europe et pour
commencer
retour donc sur les 12 premiers mois de
ce parlement européen élu en mai 2019
une année chargée et mouvementée c'est
un sujet de béatrice faisant
[Musique]
c'était il y a un an
l'eurodéputé italien sociaux-démocrates
david sassoli est élu avec 345 voix à la
présidence nous connaissons des
tournants chômage des jeunes migration
changement climatique révolution
numérique des nouveaux équilibres
mondiaux qui voit le jour nouveaux
équilibres mondiaux
nouveau visage aux européens notamment
côté français avec une europe plus
clivée vous avez finalement servi les
marchés et vous ne manquerez pas à
nombre de nos peuples et concitoyens
européens pour retourner dans votre
paradis fiscal vos amis les
multinationales que vous avez aidé
pendant le luxe l'x vous souhaite une
joyeuse retraite avec ce cadeau merci
beaucoup
départ de jean claude juncker est arrivé
de la commission von der leyen dont
certaines candidatures sont écartés par
les eurodéputés comme la française
sylvie goulard à une clean autre départ
marquant les 60 13 parlementaires
britanniques le 31 janvier
[Musique]
de nouveaux visages des institutions
européennes renouveler en profondeur
break site green deal ou encore salaire
minimum européen une année sociale et
écologique riche en perspectives
stoppé net par la crise du coronavirus
ce qui n'a pas empêché le nouveau
parlement européen de travail et même
sans siéger
[Musique]
et je suis ravi de vous accueillir ici
sur ce plateau david sassoli vous êtes
président du parlement européen vous
êtes italien vous êtes social démocrate
et je précise que vous êtes un ancien
journaliste et vous avez été lues ici
pour la première fois eurodéputé en 2009
voici pour la carte de visite bienvenus
un jeu on vient de le voir en images
quelle année vous attendiez à cela mais
cela c'est de l'histoire de cette année
le break cite la formation de la
commission du parlement
mais la crise de l'aco vide
à présent je suis heureux de constater
qu'il ya un an
les thèmes qui sont importants pour
reconstruire l'union européenne était
déjà indiqué à l'époque je pense
notamment au pacte vers la capacité que
nous devons avoir de miser sur un
continent qui doit être à la pointe de
la lutte contre les émissions de co2 je
pense que c'est là l'un des grands
sujets que nous devons défendre pour
l'avenir on y reviendra mais on va
reparler de cette crise sanitaire qui
après avoir démarré en chine s'est
abattue sur l'europe l'union européenne
at-elle été à la hauteur
j'espère qu'un jour il ya eu de
nombreuses hésitations car beaucoup de
pays ne pensais pas qu'il serait aussi
profondément touchées par cette pandémie
mais ensuite il faut le dire la réponse
a été et communale a été égale pour tous
et l'on a même pris conscience qu aucun
pays ne s'en sortiraient seul et c'est
ainsi que nous sommes aujourd'hui en
train de réfléchir à des réponses
communes contrairement à ce qui s'est
passé en 2008 ou en 2012 avec les crises
traversées par la grèce suite au lehman
brothers aujourd'hui on se rend compte
que l'europe de donner une réponse
commune et ça c'est une des leçons à
tirer peut-être de la crise sanitaire à
la nécessité notamment d'une europe de
la santé au travers peut-être d'une
agence européenne de santé
faut nous sortir de cette crise avec une
europe qui renforce surtout la santé des
femmes et des hommes
il nous faut une politique européenne et
des normes communes nous devons
renforcer notre modèle social
mais n'oublions pas en effet que au
cours de ces derniers mois
aucun citoyen européen ne s'est retrouvé
sans prise en charge donc bien d'autres
pays les soins et les traitements
étaient trop onéreux ou les gens
n'avaient pas accès à la santé publique
mais nous nous avons des forces que nous
devons sur lesquels nous devrons miser
encore plus c'est le cas de notre modèle
social qui différent de tous les autres
et la crise n'est pas terminée il ya de
nouveaux foyers de contamination qui
émerge un peu partout en europe est ce
que vous êtes inquiet de la deuxième
vague est ce que l'europe est mieux
préparée
oui nous devons être très prudents être
très attentifs en nous devons mener nos
activités économiques pour une relance
mais dans la plus grande prudence
les risques sont toujours présents nous
ne sommes pas encore sortis
nous ne savons pas ce qui arrivera après
l'été durant la crise le parlement a
continué de fonctionner les eurodéputés
depuis leur domicile ont pu pour la
première fois voté à distance c'était
important que durant la crise malgré la
crise le parlement européen continue de
fonctionner et puis parce que pour nous
la réponse devait être une réponse
démocratique par conséquent les
institutions ne pouvait pas s'arrêter
nous avons donc maintenu le parlement au
vert nous avons fait fonctionner l'union
européenne parce que les
mesures adoptées par la commission le
système show l'aide sanitaire les
interventions qui ont été faites
toutes les mesures ont été adoptées par
le parlement et donc le parlement a
permis à l'union européenne de
fonctionner et ça a été une grande
réussite pour nous on nous a demandés
nous comment on nous étions arrivés
ailleurs le congrès américain le
parlement brésilien voulait savoir
comment nous nous en étions sortis avec
eux quelle technologie et pour la
première fois nous sommes parvenus à
adopter nos des règlements en permettant
à tous les députés de participer en
provenance de 27 pays différents
alors depuis un les sessions plénières
ont repris ici à bruxelles mais pas à
strasbourg pour éviter de trop nombreux
déplacements on peut le comprendre
les sessions plénières est ce qu'elles
vont reprendre à strasbourg et si oui
quand et nous y retournerons en
septembre en septembre nous retournerons
à strasbourg et nous en sommes ravis
parce que c'est l'une de nos villes
sièges que nous avons dû quitter au
cours de ces derniers mois si difficile
difficile pour la ville de strasbourg
même mais nous voulons y retourne et
nous y retournerons en septembre et en
étant prudent bien sûr avec des
nouvelles modalités qui nous permettront
d'être présents physiquement et à
distance mais la plénière de septembre
s'est décidée aura lieu à strasbourg
avec la crise sanitaire il ya la crise
économique un qui s'en suit ce plan de
relance porté par le couple
franco-allemand 750 milliards d'euros
sur la table dont 501 milliards d'euros
de dette directe qui serait financé par
un endettement commun est-ce que vous
soutenez ce plan de relance oui ça va
c'est un plan très important il est très
important que l'on ait pu apporter une
telle réponse avec un plan qui nous
placent tout sur un plaider pied
d'égalité
donc avec un endettement commun c'est
d'ailleurs un grand sujet du passé mais
nous voyons aujourd'hui que c'est un
mécanisme qui serait utile à tout sauf à
des taux non il ya bien la nécessité
il faut à présent sciglio europe et au
delà du christophine estimant avoir une
décision du conseil européen de cette
semaine il faut notamment que le budget
de l'union européenne soit plus
ambitieux sans coupe
je pense que nos concitoyens ne
comprendraient pas que l'on réduise le
budget consacré à la recherche alors que
aujourd'hui avec cette crise de la cobi
nous nous rendons compte que nous avons
besoin de plus de recherches pour
protéger la vie des citoyens
alors concernant ce plan de relance il y
a des réticences autour de cette dette
commune de la part de plusieurs états
membres le danemark les pays-bas la
suède notamment
je vous propose d'écouter les arguments
des manuels macron pour les convaincre
mais les fameux pays frugaux dont nous
parlons il faut jamais l'oublier ce sont
des pays qui sont bénéficiaires nets du
fonctionnement du marché unique
ce sont des pays pour qu'ils participent
et un espace commun de prospérité et des
changes rapporte beaucoup beaucoup plus
qu'à d'autres et donc ça n'est pas leur
intérêt de voir certains membres et en
particulier des marchés importants de
l'économie européenne être affectés ces
sites donc de la solidarité d'avoir ces
transferts mais c'est aussi un intérêt
bien compris ce mécanisme d'endettement
commun c'est la solidarité européenne
qui est en jeu il faut réduire le fossé
le fossé entre le nord et le sud de
l'europe que la crise sanitaire est
encore creusé se dire je remonterai je
suis tout à fait d'accord avec le
président macro
bien mobile au niveau des accords che
nous devons réduire les distances entre
le nord et le sud et en même temps il
faut que les gouvernements nationaux
soient prêts à soutenir un plan de
relance qui serait d'application dans
tout l'espace européen
est ce que vous êtes optimiste qu'un
accord soit trouvé entre les 27 états
membres
si amandine 1 ce sont des négociations
nous sommes confiants de pas retenir la
meilleure des solutions
un plan de relance initié un par le
couple franco allemand le président
français qui depuis son élection en 2007
ne cesse de se déclarer pro-européen et
prône le renforcement de la souveraineté
européenne
vous êtes convaincus par les mots et
emmanuel macron par son engagement
européen
aussi si je suis très convaincu
je pense vraiment que et la ciculation
l'esu la vita dessine gorille pas
d'assurance vie des états membres c'est
l'union européenne parce qu'il faut
faire face à des défis mondiaux à des
dynamiques internationales et l'économie
je pense qu'aucun état membre d'être en
mesure de se défendre seul
je pense que ces mesures peuvent être
une protection pour tous le pays alors
il ya l'allemagne qui vient de prendre
la présidence tournante de l'union
européenne l'occasion pour l'angola
merkel de venir présenter les objectifs
pour les six mois à venir devant le
parlement européen
et pour la chancelière allemande être
européen c'est aussi partager des
valeurs home d'une facture aux 4000
sauvage président muhsin for human
interest and the price d'un jeu 10
grands trusts amènera ne rompt pas art
green man show l'heure est aux antipodes
goutte d'acier en europe à rames c'est
devenu un média grichting ya qu une
pandémie danny x 25m démocrate nancy
pelosi qui décelait euros pass et inas
and investors and green chip lead in
game fair frag
driss l'actrice kate winslet aïn skhouna
roadies room soft de groupes de l'europa
la chancelière allemande elle rappelle
une des fondations l'europe ses valeurs
ce qui soulève forcément la question de
ceux qui portent atteinte à l'état droit
et là on se tourne vers la hongrie
le premier ministre viktor orban neal a
décrété un état d'urgence très décrié
durant la crise sanitaire où ils
s'octroyaient en quelque sorte les
pleins pouvoirs encore une provocation à
l'endroit de l'union européenne qui
semble assez impuissante à réagir
fermement
et je suis tout à fait d'accord avec la
chancelière allemande merkel devant
protéger mais dans un cadre de valeurs
qui sont neuf à laval et sur bristol
sur ce point il faut faire preuve de
vigilance et de contrôle
alors concernant la hongrie le parlement
européen et n'a eu de cesse d'alerter
les institutions soient la détérioration
de l'état droit il ya plus de deux ans
la procédure de sanction de l'article 7
du traité sur le qui peut aboutir à une
suspension du droit de vote de la
hongrie a été déclenché mais malgré cela
l'europe elle a quand même du mal à
faire respecter ces valeurs
sur l'ensemble
du territoire européen avec peut-être
d'été de tentations autoritaires
nous nous demandons que le plan de
relance il faut que les fonds du cadre
financier pluriannuel de l'union impose
des conditions en matière de respect de
l'état de droit et de notre côté nous
attendons que du côté du conseil y ait
des indications claires parce que pour
le parlement ce serait difficile à
accepter de ne pas avoir de règles en
matière de respect de l'état de droit et
donc avec le conseil être très clair et
à suivre le cap indiqué par la
chancelière merkel autres pays
régulièrement sous le feu des critiques
pour des violations libertés publiques
c'est la pologne les élections
présidentielles elles viennent d'avoir
lieu et le président sortant le
conservateur en place jude à a été réélu
de justesse au détriment du candidat
libéral pro-européen
est ce que c'est une chance manquée pour
les polonais de peut-être renouer un
dialogue plus serein avec le reste de
l'europe
ben ali jama l'elcom et commenter le
résultat des élections mais ce que je
constate c'est que dans la société
polonaise
on voit qu'il ya une poussée européiste
alors l'épreuve 20 n'ont pas remporté
les élections mais il y à une poussée de
ce mouvement et je pense que le nouveau
gouvernement devra tenir compte de cela
il ya beaucoup de jeunes et une majorité
des jeunes polonais et des habitants de
la pologne qui ont une vocation
européenne
est ce que vous constatez comme beaucoup
une fracture plus importante entre
l'europe de l'est et l'europe de l'ouest
mon coin movin toyota événements je
pense que comme on le disait bien
instant on doit tout faire pour
rapprocher le nord et le sud mais
également l'est et l'ouest du continent
il ya de nombreuses questions qui
concernent certains pays et qui devrait
être comment dire d'être
[Musique]
affronter plus en profondeur je pense
qu'ils pourraient faire son union
europénne aujourd'hui grand nombre de
gouvernements devraient faire preuve
d'un peu plus de prudence surtout
lorsque l'on parle de valeurs
fondamentales mais mille vingt sept
états membres de l'union lequel pourrait
s'en sortir sans l'europe actuellement
il y en a qui a choisi de sortir de
l'union européenne c'est le royaume uni
et c'est une première depuis la le début
de la construction européenne
les négociations autour du bric site
elles sont au point mort même si le
premier ministre boris johnson veut
aller vite
winch clics seulement
david sassoli on veut faire traîner les
choses vraiment ici à bruxelles
non non nous nous sommes tout à fait
disposés à négocier
nous avons adopté des résolutions nous
souhaitons respecter les accords tati et
ont conclu en janvier
novaes de la graine des spins jour
véritable passion du côté des autorités
britanniques pour arriver à un accord et
nous en sommes désolés nous pensons
qu'il vaut mieux arriver à un accord
mais s'il n'y a pas d'accord nous nous
défendrons les principes les règles et
l'autonomie du marché européen
ça c'est notre droit et nous le
défendrons jusqu'au bout les points
d'achoppement ils sont nombreux à la
pêche les normes environnementales
fiscale sociale la question là la
juridiction de la cour européenne de
justice si au 31 2020 en effet ledit
forcée est effectué sans accord la faute
à qui credo quai
la colle pas dit qu'ils nommèrent je
pense que la faute
ce sera celle de celui qui ne fait pas
tous les efforts pour arriver à un
accord nous nous faisons tout ce qu'il
faut nous avons même si on est d'accord
vie des blocages opposés d'avoir
quelques mois en plus vu de blocage
suite à l'accord vite nous avons demandé
quelques mois en plus pour arriver à
conclure cet accord
donc la responsabilité se trouve de
celui qui ne fait pas tout pour arriver
à un accord
mais d'autre part nous nous respectons
les décisions prises par les autorités
britanniques
tout comme nous avons respecté la
décision prise par les citoyens
britanniques au biscione qu'edf hors
quota que du côté du royaume uni on est
également touchée par les contrecoups de
la qu'ovide ont reçu des informations
des données économiques qui sont ou
toulouse
vous voulez dire que le royaume uni
durant cette crise s'en sort finalement
moins bien sans l'union européenne que
les 27 états membres
ensemble non non vous savez moi je ne
juge pas le royaume uni où je prends
acte de la décision qu'ils ont prise
avec douleur
nous avons dit au revoir à nos collègues
députés britanniques
évidemment chacun est libre du show
qu'il fait nous pensons qu'il vaut mieux
avoir un accord plutôt que pas d'accord
et je pense qu'il est possible d'arriver
à un accord
novedia modèle du côté des autorités
britanniques nous on ne voit pas
d'enthousiasmé pour arriver à cet accord
et ça nous préoccupe bien évidemment
c'est très clair il y en a un qui s'en
réjouit de ce break site en tout cas
c'est le président américain fervent
défenseur du rexy les relations
diplomatiques et commerciales avec les
états unis elles sont loin d'être simple
c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire
elles se sont détériorées donald trump
est ce qu'il joue contre l'europe
ah non il continué nous restons
convaincus
par le multilatéralisme et le fond de
rapports des relations d'amitié avec les
etats-unis une relation historique avec
son mari on va d'un terreau de tous de
renforcer cette relation mais nous
voyons également que certains alors le
passé ont tenté de diviser l'europe
nous ne pouvons pas laisser passer cela
l'urgence de la pandémie qui frappe la
planète actuellement je pense que la
collaboration entre l'union européenne
et les etats unis pourrait être un signe
de force plutôt que de faiblesses et que
cela pourrait servir à tout le monde
nous nous restons convaincus par un
monde où il ya le multilatéralisme le
royaume uni qui s'en va d'autres pays
qui souhaitent intégrer l'union
européenne est ce que c'est le bon
moment notamment pour ouvrir des
négociations concrètes avec l'albanie la
macédoine et oui les lignes en europe
union européenne reste un pays est un
pari pour beaucoup de pays qui
souhaitent nous rejoignez nous rejoindre
oui tout à fait l'europe attire c'est
une référence
les balkans occidentaux nous les
attendons un prince offert nous suivons
ce qui se passe au niveau du processus
d'adhésion
nous nous sommes battus pour lancer ce
processus avec l'albanie la macédoine du
nord
hier j'ai rencontré le premier ministre
monténégrin donc d'un pays candidat en
suit leur évolution
on voit quelles sont les réformes
entreprises et nous les encourageons on
a besoin d'eux mais permettra
d'éclaircir la carte géographique de
l'europe de reconstruire
un espace géopolitique ou politiques et
le faire coïncider avec l'espace
géographique et je pense que ça il en va
de l'intérêt de tout le monde
est ce que vous êtes favorable à une
europe qui serait davantage une europe à
plusieurs vitesses c'est à dire qu'il ya
un socle commun mais que des états
membres ne correspondant pas à certains
critères ne puisse pas participer à
toutes les politiques communes
non mais oh non non me back donc c'est
pas du tout quelque chose pour laquelle
je me bats moi je me bats pour une
politique commune de l'union européenne
qui profite aux 27 états membres
ça doit être mon objectif faire
plusieurs vitesses c'est impliquerait
que l'europe n'est pas en mesure de
faire face avec un front uni aux défis
qui se posent à elle
là aussi c'est très clair alors là où
l'europe a encore une très grande marge
de progression assez sur son rayonnement
de très nombreux européens parmi
lesquels les français méconnaissent les
institutions mais aussi les
personnalités européennes
le résumé en chiffres avec béatrice
faisant
[Musique]
connaissez vous ce visage ou celui ci
non vous n'êtes pas seuls et cela n'a
rien à voir avec le port du masque
selon un sondage réalisé en février par
viavoice les français connaissent mal
voire très mal les personnalités
européennes sur un échantillon de 1000
personnes interrogées en ligne entre le
5 et le 7 février 2020 une petite moitié
seulement connais l'existence de michel
barnier négociateur en chef du brésil et
de thierry breton en charge du numérique
et le chiffre ne fait que baisser dès
qu'on interroge les français sur nos
voisins européens comme ursula von der
leyen non seulement 26% prétend de la
connaître pourtant président de la
commission européenne
même sort pour charles michel président
du conseil européen connu seulement par
17% des sondés
en bas du tableau le moins connu de tous
et pourtant élu par le plus grand nombre
l italien david sassoli président du
parlement européen depuis un an
[Musique]
david sassoli 84% des français ne savent
pas qui vous êtes je vous ai entendu
réagir à un peu plus souvent en france
vous a entendu réagir durant le sujet
vous avez dit normal c'est embêtant de
même par rapport à d'autres institutions
il est normal que le président du
parlement européen sont moins connus
mais je m'engage à venir plus souvent en
france et on vous invite comment
expliquez-vous ce fossé entre les
citoyens européens ils union les
institutions elles paraissent si éloigné
six hors de portée que les européens ne
s'y intéresse même pas et auquel je
pense que qu'actuellement cette tendance
n'existe pas je pense qu'il y en attente
positive et bien une attente en matière
de confiance vis-à-vis de l'europe un
grand nombre de citoyens un grand nombre
de pays ont compris que sans en europe
il ne serait sans doute pas possible de
reconstruire leur économie
je pense que pour le moment il ya une
inversion de tendance avec une perte de
confiance qui arrive alors pour inclure
les citoyens dans la construction
européenne va être lancé d'ici la fin de
l'année la conférence sur l'avenir de
l'europe
l'idée intégrer les citoyens justement
au débat et le parlement compte y tenir
un rôle clé expliquez nous comment est
concrètement ça va se passer comment
cette conférence sur l'avenir et on a
hélas comme le défi de la législature de
souhaitons entamer un dialogue avec les
citoyens et citoyennes européen avec les
institutions les parlements nationaux
pour bien définir certains mécanismes de
réforme du processus européen pour
rendre la démocratie européenne
vous efficace un progrès soient mieux
oui lesquelles sont à moins
bureaucratique
nous avons besoin de réformes eh bien
nous aussi ici à europe hebdo on
souhaite rapprocher les institutions
européennes des citoyens et nous allons
accueillir notamment un premier citoyen
c'est un niklas moon qu'il est allemand
il est étudiant en journalisme il est
depuis paris il a 24 ans et je crois
qu'il a une question pour vous bonjour
monsieur d'anthony dément bien je
parlais beaucoup que vous pouvez
maintenant pour le mouvement
la glace matin mais plutôt propre du
terme c'est à dire sachant que l'union
européenne et oriane de prix nobel de la
paix denba sy bocuse dans l'être à mort
hier des milliers de migrants dans la
mer beaucoup d'encre outre quand même
comme d'une commune prima je pense que
l'europe sans politics migratoires elle
est faible un fragile mais ça n'aide pas
nos états membres
répondre à cette grande question qui
nous préoccupe a pendant de nombreuses
années la question migratoire ravi
d'avoir vu dans le programme de la
présidence allemande que l'on parle de
l'importance d'une politique commune en
matière d'immigration c'est une grande
bataille une bataille de conscience et
de civilisation et le problème ce n'est
pas ce pacte passé ce péché original ce
pacte passé avec la turquie il ya
quelques années si nous rend dépendants
nous sommes très préoccupés par la
situation et par nos rapports avec la
turquie
le parlement européen
exprimez clairement ne suffit pas de
lever la voix il ya certains éléments à
respecter par rapport à la grèce par
rapport à chypre la réponse européenne
doit être très concrète concrète à
distance toujours mais maintenant depuis
l'angleterre depuis cambridge trégor
crêpes si les français il a 50 ans il
est informaticien et je crois qu'il a
une question à vous poser sans surprise
autour du bric site
on les écoute c'est ça se lit il y à de
réelles possibilités maintenant que
l'école devienne indépendante d'ici
quelques années
à votre avis quelles sont ses chances
d'accéder à l'union européenne assez
rapidement alors moi je ne veux pas me
mêler des dynamiques internes au royaume
uni vous connaissez la position du
parlement européen
nous n'avons pas stigmatiser
la décision prise à propos du président
c'est une décision qui a été prise par
les citoyens britanniques toute
évolution au sein même de l'ue ni du
royaume uni et bien nous la suivons
attentivement
là ce seront les mots de la fin merci
david c'est celui d'avoir été notre
invité exceptionnel et on espère vous
voir en france très bientôt
vous pouvez voir et revoir cette
émission en replay sur le site internet
de public sénat
à très bientôt je l'espère pour de
nouvelles aventures européennes
[Musique]